another thing dr bright is not allowed  to do dr bright is not allowed to  accidentally spill green gelatin on a  dead body it is well known by scp staff  particularly those in the o5 council  that allowing  scp-447's green slime to come into  contact with the dead body will result  in disaster on a catastrophic scale of  course dr bright decided that it would  be hilarious to procure some lime jell-o  from the canteen pretend to trip and  fall and spill the gelatin all over a  body being observed by the o5 admittedly  the first time it was a bit funny but it  was also extremely stressful multiple  staff fainted and 05-2 made it a point  to tell dr bright that he owed him a new  pair of khakis after the sudden terror  had made him well ruin his